it's time for a review he's filming
everything like it's pretty buy this
stuff that turns him into an alien but
it's okay cuz the big bad government
wants to use him like AI want to reason
with him or work out something so the
eviction guy he prints this one other
Indian he wants to get out of the slums
because get this there's a human gang
leader their bodies so that blows
everybody up Haitian guy is like we need
another pizza and understanding along
with my giant robot so these mission guy
stays behind while the one who helped
the mouth goes up to the mothership
mothership the men behind the camera is
informing me that district 9 is in fact
not a comedy but it is in fact a trauma
I am most perplexing mitad really this
was supposed to be taken seriously when
no Jerry was the greatest job I've ever
seen
like I mean I just seen what people mean
when they say this is the most original
filming year you see they tried to
portray racism without actually using
race and nobody's ever done that before
except for alienation x-men and a move
on to Day the Earth Stood Still and
anything having to do with Star Trek but
they do it in this documentary shaky-cam
style and nobody's ever done that before
except for Blair Witch Project Bunny IDs
maker clover for you and Divya facility
office but it also has a lot of shot
coordinates which just about every scary
will be done in the past ten years I've
done but it makes this comedy and drama
which goes all the way back to the
Shakespearean Age and giant robots
blowing things up lord knows we haven't
seen that yet something else how does
that know this is confusing or taken
from something else
it's called battening in the Terminator
go to Jurassic Park ray everyone will be
calling me a cinematic maverick and you
thought it was just some bum on the
street with no original ideas
oh this meeting is a quick big tub of
pretentiousness I wonder in Baz Luhrmann
is in town he smells like Jimmy this is
jittery boom scene I needed to make my
sequel Batman Terminator in a Steven
Seagal Christmas